Lâm thiên nào đến nực 2,5 gản tấn thếm máy phòng, nặng tương đương vương mùi tắm ngàn ô tô năm chỗ,
linh định của sinh và đậu ngay. Đây là PVF, sinh và đậu lưỡng thứ 2 Việt Nam với sự chữa sống mình ngàn chút
nồi đang được thi công tại hương nhiên. Dìm đặc biệt của công trình, là hệ máy có thể nống
phọc mở chỉ trong mùi 2 đến 2 mi phút. Vậy máy phòng khổng lồ này được thi công như thế nào?
Chúc tiền, các kỳ sự lắp dự 2 giầm vòng hoặc thẹp dài 2 chăm sóm ước chiếm mẹp,
hối giấm nặng gần của những nặng tấn được kép từ hàng trăm cấu kệ thẹp.
Đây là 2 giữa xúc của chắc lớn nhất của mại viện vụ là chính của mình đỡ mại,
dùng các bạn cầu xíu trường xíu trường xíu trường trường, các bạn xam lắm nơi đến 1 gình 2 trăm nơi tấn để cầu
các cầu kệ cánh dặng kế cấu lắp tổ hợp phần bộ hệ máy đóng ngở.
Sau khi toàn bộ kết tổ máy được lắp giấm dưỡng mật đất, công chính bước vào cú đoạn quan trọng nhất,
kích nâng đồng bộ. Hẹt thống tuy lực sẽ nâng quan bộ kết tổ máy lên bốn chủ đo chính,
các khoảng 20,5 mắt bằng mê tân cuối thác để cố lịch.
Theo các tí sự, đây là hạm mục có độ khó rất cao, không chỉ vì khối lượng kết cấu khổng lộ,
mà còn đoạn hỏi và tíu trình nghiêm lạc, đợi lú thợ tăng nghề cao và nhiều tiếp bị trân dụng được vi đồng từ cả trong và ngoài nước.
Mọi người theo là chúng tôi sẽ đi mong quan trọng vi, để lắm đặt các mên sắc,
cào, rầm phố, h held juj wheel, sát tạo thành một vẻ máy món.
Sau hơn chính tháng tí công, giữ an đa đặt hơn sống với mình trong chiến đồ.
Hẹn có hơn 3,5 kí sự công nhân đăng làm việc tại công trường.
Giữ an khởi công này mùi sấu thống mười năm 2,5 mẹn lắm.
Giữ kiến hoàn thành vào thử 3,5 mẹn.